>> WELCOME BACK TO OUR SPECIAL
BROADCAST OF INSIDE TISSUES
FOR THE -- INSIDE THE ISSUES
FOR THE HOUR.
THE CAMPAIGN TO LEGALIZE
MARIJUANA CONTINUES TO GAIN
MOMENTUM NOT JUST THIS COUNTRY
BUT AROUND THE WORLD.
CANADA JUST LEGALIZED IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNALED HIS
WILLINGNESS TO END THE FEDERAL
BAN ON MARIJUANA.
MANY PEOPLE THINK THAT IS
GREAT.
FORMER CONGRESSMAN PATRICK
KENNEDY FEELS UNEASY ABOUT IT.
HE WROTE A PIECE IN THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" WARNING
LEGALIZING MARIJUANA COULD BE
BAD FOR KIDS AND HE WOULD SET
BACK THE CAUSE OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
WE SPOKE TO HIM EARLIER ABOUT
THIS.
SO AM INTERESTING TO HEARING
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THIS.
ONE OF THE ONLY PEOPLE, ONE OF
THE ONLY DEMOCRATS TO SAY
ANYTHING LIKE THIS OUT LOUD.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
REASONING IS.
>> WE HAVE BEEN WITH THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE CURRENT
OPIOID CRISIS AND EVERYBODY IS
POINTING BACK TO WHERE THEY
MARKETED THE ADDICTIVE
OXYCONTIN.
WHAT WAS ENDING UP HAPPENING
IS PUBLIC HEALTH GOT PUT TO
THE SIDELINES WHILEM PROFITS
FOR PURDUE PHARMA RULED THE
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WE GO BACK A GENERATION TO THE
TOBACCO INDUSTRY SETTLEMENT
AND HOW WE HAD TO LEARN FOR A
LONG TIME TO THE FACT THAT
THERE WAS AN APICKTIVE
SUBSTANCE -- ADDICTIVE
SUBSTANCE IN NICOTINE
MARKETING THE COMMERCIAL
MARKETING OF THE CIGARETTES.
SO WITH ALL OF THAT KNOWLEDGE
WHY WOULD BE SURPRISED IF WE
IS A NEW COMMERCIAL PUSH, TO
PUSH A PRODUCT OUT CALLED
MARIJUANA THERE THERE WOULDN'T
BE A DELETERIOUS IMPACT ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH?
ESPECIALLY KNOWING THAT
LEGALIZATION MEANS
COMMERCIALIZATION.
WHICH REALLY MEANS --
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND.
WAIT A SECOND, CONGRESSMAN.
WE KNOW THE PEOPLE WHO RUN THE
MARIJUANA COMPANIES ARE COOL,
PROGRESSIVE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT IN THIS FOR THE
MONEY.
THEY ARE IN IT BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE.
WHY DON'T YOU TRUST THEM?
>> WELL, THAT IS THE THING WE
HAVE TO ASK OF OURSELVES.
ARE THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
NOW GOING INTO INVESTING INTO
CANNABIS AND IN THE MANY
PRODUCTS THAT ARE BEING
PRODUCED?
I MIGHT ADD ELIXIRS THE
PHANTOM GRAPE AID AND ORANGE
AID THAT WE GREW UP WITH
INFUSED WITH THE MARIJUANA
INFUSED T.H.C.
BEYOND JUST THE BROWNIES, THE
MARIJUANA INDUSTRY IS NOW
INFUSING GUMMY BEARS.
THEY ARE INFUSING THINGS LIKE
POT-TARTS.
OTHER FOOD EDIBLES IS WHAT
THEY ARE KNOWN.
IN OTHER WORDS THIS IS A
REALLY SLICK, VERY SMART
MARKETING EFFORT IF YOU HAVE
MONEY ON THE LINE BEHIND THE
MARIJUANA INDUSTRY.
YOU ARE STANDING TO GAIN A LOT
OF MONEY IN THE YEARS AHEAD.
AND YET, WHO IS GOING TO BE
THE BIGGEST ONE TO PAY FOR ALL
OF THIS?
IT WILL BE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT PAYS THE COST OF THIS.
IT WILL BE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING TO THINK THAT THIS
IS AN EASY ALTERNATIVE FOR ME
TO DEAL WITH MY STRESS AND
ANXIETY BECAUSE NOW I HAVE ALL
THE CHOICES.
I CAN DRINK IT, I CAN SMOKE
IT, I CAN EAT IT.
WHATEVER WILL HELP ME PEOPLE
LESS ANXIOUS.
AND FRANKLY, TUCKER, AMIDST
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND THE
ADDICTION CRISIS IT'S SHOCKING
WE ARE NOT ASKING A MORE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION, WHAT ARE
WE DOING TO HELP OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE MANAGE THEIR STRESS,
COPE WITH THEIR PROBLEMS,
NAVIGATE THEIR ANXIETYS?
>> Tucker: THAT IS RIGHT.
>> THAT SHOULD BE THE
CHALLENGE ON THE COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
YET, I THINK WE ARE SELLING
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE DOWN THE
RIVER BY ALLOWING A NEW
PREDATORY BUSINESS THAT FEEDS
OFF OF ADDICTION, THAT MAKES
MONEY OFF OF GETTING PEOPLE
HOOKED.
I THINK IT'S BAD FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU 100%.
BY THE WAY, I SHOULD NOTE FOR
THE VIEWERS WHO DON'T KNOW YOU
PERSONALLY OVERCAME ADDICTION
TO DRUGS AND ALCOHOL WITHOUT
THE USE OF MORE DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL AND YOU ARE A BETTER